what's going on guys today we're going
to break down all evidence from my
academia that indicates dabby will steal
an ice quirk before his final fight with
endeavour
manga spoiler warning ahead but we all
know throughout the series there's been
a lot of foreshadowing for certain
events
whether it be all mike's death midoriya
mastering all his quirks or derby being
toyotaroki which turned out to be true
recently in the mag we got strong
foreshadowing for something else that's
bound to happen
and that is endeavoring shoto going
head-to-head against toyah himself
in chapter 302 ray straight up says you
have no choice but to fight darby
and a few chapters later the villain
makes it clear he's ready to go even
further than he did during the war
to me this indicates two things number
one they are going to fight
and number two in order for toyo to go
even further and actually kill them this
time
he'll need to have some kind of physical
upgrade even the most
hardcore derby fan would have to admit
that right now he has no chance of
beating your dad in a real fight
i mean during the war it was different
because endeavour was so shocked he
couldn't move a muscle
but the next time they meet i doubt it
would be the same thing in chapter 301 a
doctor revealed that derby's physique is
better suited for an ice quirk
as he was born to withstand freezing
temperatures instead of the intense
flames he produces
that's why he always has burns after a
fight and in this way hirokoshi has made
a character that simply can't win
against the one man he's so desperate to
beat
his flames might be the hottest however
his technique just isn't on the same
level as the top hero
and even if it was his body can't handle
the fire for too long
things will have to change for him
before he faces his father again and
with suguraki now having the power of
all for one
it's within his abilities to steal the
quirk of one person and pass it to
another
for the rest of the video we're about to
break down who the quirk will be taken
from
how toyo might use it and why this will
ruin endeavour's life
before we get into it though be sure to
smash that sub button and notification
bell if you want to see more stuff like
this
and drop a like as it does help out the
channel okay so starting with how dabi
might use an ice quirk
there are at least two different kinds
that we need to consider on one hand you
have ice powers like shoto's that enable
the users to generate ice from their own
body
and then on the other hand you have
people like getting who can manipulate
ice in various ways
but seemingly can't produce it from
nothing for those that might not know
getting is a long time member of the
liberation army
and his ice manipulation allows him to
control the temperature of ice as well
as its movement and its shape
either of these abilities would be
suited to derby given that his body is
literally built for this
so the question is which one will suit
him best and in my opinion it would be
this one
because by generating ice he can use it
to cool himself down by using ice to
counteract the negative effects of his
fire
toy would be able to use flames for an
extended period of time not to mention
he could stop doing that thing where he
just keeps on talking to give himself
time to recover
additionally it gives him more options
to attack with including the heaven
piercing ice wall
and obviously attacks that combine both
ice and fire
this would make darby equal to endeavour
during their next battle as although his
dad has the better technique
he would have the superior flames and
better stamina when it comes to
overheating
contrastingly if he was to steal
getting's power he wouldn't be able to
internally cool himself down in the same
way
plus from a strategic point of view it
makes no sense for the villains to make
one of their strongest people quirkless
getting had mastered his power after
years and years of training
so to take it from him and give it to
the untrained derby would probably be
the stupidest thing they could do
in theory i guess if they free dr garaki
he could make a duplicate version of
getting squirk and then give that copy
to toya
but there is a much easier way for him
to get an upgrade within the todoroki
family there are three potential
candidates who could have their ice
quilts transferred to derby
and those are rey fiumi and natsuo
starting with rey it's all but confirmed
that her ability is the exact same with
shoto's ice creation
as we saw her use it to cool his face
down after she threw the boiling water
during the sports festival shoto will
also explicitly refer to his icy side as
her quirk
which is something you wouldn't really
say unless it's the same on top of that
when endeavour was younger he was
looking for someone to have a quirk
marriage with
and it stands to reason that he only
approached rey in the first place
because she has such a great power
moving on to fuyumi now chapter 291
stated that she inherited that same
quirk but naturally endeavour didn't
train her since he wanted a child who
had ice and fire
natsuwa was born years later and while
it's not outright said what his quirk is
everything implies that he generates ice
like everyone else this means debbie has
several options when choosing which
todoroki to steal a quirk from
and whoever he picks would likely be the
one that would hurt endeavour the most
the paranormal liberation war proves
that toyo feels nothing for anyone in
the todoroki family
as he even regretted that nacho wasn't
killed by one of the villains he sent to
their location
so all that matters to him is hurting
endeavor and he'll do whatever he can to
make that happen
whether it's killing shoto revealing the
truth about their past or stealing the
quirk of someone he loves
the villains easily have enough
resources to kidnap one member of the
todorokis and harvest their quirk
and i think endeavour would be most hurt
if they kidnapped for yumi
i say this because she was always the
one trying to hold the family together
when everything was a mess
and she was also usually the one sibling
who tried to get along with their dad
if the yumi is held hostage by the
liberation front then she'd likely try
to get through to her brother and make
him see what he's doing is wrong
however given that he's a crazy person i
doubt it'd make much of a difference
shigoraki could then upgrade darby by
doing a quirk transfer using all for one
and part of me thinks she would allow it
to be taken without putting up any
resistance
she'd know she has no chance fighting
back against the villains and on some
level i think fuumi understands why toya
is trying to hurt endeavour
even if she doesn't agree with his
methods after the transfer is done
they'd likely keep her as a hostage to
use as leverage against the number one
hero
because if they threaten to kill her or
turn her into a nomu then it might make
him never hesitate
anyway with fiumi's eyes toy would
become a mirror image of shoto
as they both possess the exact same
capabilities whereas one sibling is the
natural-born creation the endeavor
wanted
darby could be the evil frankenstein
version that's the result of his
terrible parenting
from a young age toy was told he had the
potential to surpass all might
only to then be told he couldn't be a
hero once he started getting burns
and in his mind his father replaced him
with shoto
this is funny because rey warned
endeavor that having more kids to make
them heroes would be too painful for
toya
but he went and did it anyway and i see
what derby could be the final
consequence of that decision
when they come face to face he could
taunt his father over the fact he stole
for yumi's quirk
and that would definitely make endeavour
suffer more than anything toy has done
so far
by playing these mind games debbie could
throw the number one hero off his game
and you know make him unfocused
and this could potentially create an
opening for debbie to kill him i think
it'd be the most poetic ending if engie
was killed by the very same hybrid
ability that he was so desperate for his
kids to have
and if he does die then it would pave
the way for these two to go 1v1
shoto would of course be more skilled
with his icy side whereas debbie would
be the reverse
so it'd make for a pretty interesting
encounter let me know in the comments
down below do you think toyo will take
for yumi's ice quirk
or do you think he's more likely he'll
go for someone else instead whatever you
think thank you for watching
and be sure to hit that sub button as
i'd appreciate your support on the road
to 400k
until the next one peace out